et au retour
mon mari voulait qu'on aille un
restaurant que j'adore ce qu'il est
vieux comme moi et j'adore les peintures
qui a dansé le train bleu à la gare de
lyon si vous avez vous fait une touba
récemment malfato dans un train et
mademoiselle qui va la passer dans une
gare j'espère hutu talent éclate et on
pourrait y aller avec vous parce qu'on
adore le train bleu ont rejoint le
quatuor tab est ce ma faute au hashtag
grosse loose de saint valentin et vous
serez sélectionné à un moment dans la
soirée elle est votre pire
saint-valentin votre meilleur isabelle
cyr saint valentin on était très encore
plus jeunes avec mon mari s'était
arrêtée dès maintenant les siennes en
asie wars et devienne un soir de saint
valentin il céder tiens si on essayait
le préservatif à préserver n'avons
jamais me ressemble on a acheté un truc
qui se trouve en allemagne des
préservatifs avec la tête de mickey
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je te suis
jusque là mais j'ai une question les
oreilles wallonie et je ne risque que la
lourdeur des vraies petites oreilles
louis forzy c'est le reste est arrivé
pas compris un truc c'est bien sur ses
vêtements il en utilise et peut il l'a
déroulait d'abord ça marche bien on a
joué aux marionnettes parce que
franchement je ne sais pas il n'y a que
dans cette émission qu'on passe dans des
moments pareils
merci d'abeilles c'est la plus belle
anecdote que j'ai entendu de mes
machines famille alors le présent au
mickey c'est cool non parce qu'on
voulait pas du tout ici vous avez
jusqu'à les marques dacia pas eu un
aller-retour à mèze forme avec mickey
qui regardaient à côté mais il a lancé
il a renoncé à la chose via leur
m'amusant dessiné sur la casse est
exactement une tête de mickaël en
plusieurs personnages de disney genre
disney a bien changé
vraiment